[音楽]
こんにちははめです皆さんは飲むゼリーと
いうものをご存知でしょうかゼリー
いろんな種類ありますちっちゃめのカップ
でなんかチュって食べれるやつだったり
でかいゼリーでこうスプーンですって
食べるやつそしてウィダーエンゼリのよう
に片手でこうスピーディにグっと飲める
とても便利な飲むゼリというものもあり
ますおい飲むゼリー調べてみたらあまりに
多かったです今回日本国内のノームゼリー
120種類をこちらに集めましたもうね
多分ほとんどの飲むゼリーはここにある
はずですめっちゃ頑張って集めましたまあ
みんな知っているでしょうウダイゼリー
これも結構有名だと思うんだよな速攻元気
カロリーメイトとかも3種類もあるんすよ
飲むゼリーバージョンがもう本当に言い
出すと止まんないぐらいたくさん飲む
ゼリーありますデカビタとかもあるのよ
飲むゼリーバージョンがバイタルとか
ミニッツメイドとか1日分のビタミンとか
もなんかねあのそのあのそのあのそのあの
そのいっぱいあるいっぱいあるしなんか
キャラもポケモンとかアンパンマンとか
クーとかもあってすご種類が多いんです
けれどもこれだけ飲むゼリー種類が多いと
さどれを飲めばいいかわからないこんなに
あったらどれを飲めばいいか迷うよね正直
あの俺
はどれでもいい俺は飲むずにそんななんか
こだわりがなくてこれが1番好きですとか
ないからどれでもいいんですけどもし飲む
ずり飲むんだったら一番美味しいやつ飲み
たいじゃないですかというわけで今回は
全部飲み
ます語弊がありました全部飲むわけじゃ
ないですけど全種類飲みます全種類飲んで
1番なんか好みのゼリーはどれかなって
いうのを決めますがそれがメインじゃあり
ません全種類の飲むゼリーを合わせると
どんな味になるのかかなり研究進んでると
思いますもう昔こんな種類なかったと思う
んだなんか気づいたら増えててやっぱ楽な
んだろうね飲むのが10秒チャージみたい
な忙しい現代社会人を助ける飲むゼリー
全部合わせるとどんな味になるのか
ちょっと全部ぶちまぜて地上最強に
美味しい飲むゼリーを作ってみたいと思い
ますでは行こう
はいというわけで早速120種類の飲む
ゼリー混ぜていき
ましょうよいしょはいこの巨大なパンドラ
のボックスにどんどんぶち込んでいこうと
思いますでは行きましょう記念すべき第1
コメこちらウイダーインゼリーの
エネルギーこの青いのがはなんか一番
メジャーな気がしますねマスカット味
なんかこれよく言われるのがおにぎり1個
分のエネルギーがあるよって言われてます
その実力いかにいただき
[音楽]
ますうまなんかすごい美味しいんだよな
普通に
これうん変わらない味って感じです一口の
ね残りをどんどんここにぶっ込んでいき
ますこんな感じですちょっと今はその綺麗
ではないけど溜まっていくとどんどんね色
とかも変わってくと思うから色も味も
楽しめる面白企画ですどんどん行き
ましょうウダイゼリプロテインタンパク質
プロテイン入ってるんだすごい
[音楽]
う白いうわあまざってなんかやばいことに
なってきてる
うわあザパみたいごごご飯履いた後みたい
になっちゃったウダイジリマルチビタミン
緑ビタミンも取れるやつです
[音楽]
ねうん飲みやすいでやっぱ青が一番
美味しいんだよ
な黄色いなんかビタミン系って黄色いよね
全部1日分のマルチビタミン0kcalな
のかな0kcalで1日分のビタミン取れ
るってもうこれしかないやんいただき
ますえ飲みやすパイナップル味で美味しい
あこれも黄色いああやばい目玉焼きみたい
になってきてるウダイゼリ鉄分マルチ
ミネラル大事ですいただき
ますいやグレープで美味しいんだけどね青
の方がやっぱり全然美味しいわグレープっ
てだけあってちょっと紫色っぽいウダイ
ゼリープロテイン15gめっちゃ入ってる
ないただき
ますこれは筋肉つきそうですねウダイ
ローヤルゼリほうこんなのも今あるんだ
いただきますうん美味しいアミノ酸とかク
酸とか入ってますねやっぱゼリー系って
なんか体にいいの多いよなウダイゼリー
ブドと考えるためのエネルギーいただき
ます甘くて美味しい受験生とかおすすめ
ですウダイゼリーまるで桃の食感美味し
そううわフルーティーだウダイゼリまるで
メロンの
感あメロン苦手だったやばいメロン苦手な
のに苦手ってことは多分リアルにメロンの
味再現できると思いますすごいね
ウィダーインゲーミングゼリーゲームする
用のウィダー出てんだ何味なんだろう味
書いてないけどいただき
ますなんか何とは言わんけど立ちそうな味
です元気が出る味ですねこれこれで今飲む
ゼリーの王道ウダイゼリーシリーズは全て
入れ終わりました一応全部入れるとこんな
感じの見た目になって
ますうわなんかエキセントリックだな宇宙
想像みたいな色合いになってるこれはこれ
で綺麗なのかもしれませんさあ120種類
もあるから全然まだありますどんどん入れ
ていきましょうカロリーメイトゼリー
ライマンドグレーパーツいただきます俺は
固形の方が好きかなカロリーメイトゼリー
フルーティミルクいただきますあ飲み
やすい焦げの方がいいかな
カロリーメイトゼリーアップル味りんご
いただきますあなんかこれは好き速攻元気
アミノサ&ロイヤルゼリーこれめっちゃ
コンビニで見ますねあと美味しかった気が
するんだよないただきます
ああ好きな味エナジードリンクチックの味
しますねこれは美味しいです速攻元気クエ
ザとビタミンC酸っぱくて飲みやすい速攻
元高齢ニンジンプラス何が速攻元気になっ
ちゃうんでしょうかあ飲みやすいあけど
後味がしっかりきますね
すごい色速攻元気エネルギー&マルチ
ビタミン飲みやすそうわほぼウダの青だ
速攻元気だとこれが一番好きかな最高です
速攻元気鉄分&マルチビタミンこれは鉄分
取りやすそうスーっと飲めますいいね速攻
元気盗塁ゼロヘルシーなのも出てんのね
ああさすが盗塁ゼロなんか味薄めだけど
ちゃんと元気出るなって感じです
こんにゃく畑ブド味こんにゃく畑も飲む
ゼリーバージョン出てるんだちっちゃい
カップ型のイメージが強いですいただき
ます
うまうまこれこん畑やっぱうめえんだな
こにゃ畑マスカット味おめえ変わらない
味っって感じですねこんにゃく畑大つ
アロエインりんご
味
うめえこにゃ畑桃味飲めないから美味し
そうグッディ俺これ初めて見ましたメイ
バランスっていうシリーズがたくさんあり
ますマスカットヨーグルトは味はどのもの
かいただきますう栄養もりモりって感じの
味ですねなるほどねこういうのか結構白い
なメイバランスストロベリーヨーグルト
[音楽]
味栄養強めメイバランス蜂蜜ヨーグルト味
このね6大栄養素というのがねやばい
なんか全部盛りしてるからなのかなんかね
美味しさというより栄養の方にほと疲れ
入れてるなっていう感じがしますいただき
ますほらねメイバランスブドウヨーグルト
味栄養メイバランスヨーグルト味栄養
やっぱね楽してね栄養って取れるもんじゃ
ないのよメイバランスピーチヨーグルト味
いただきますあ飲むふりしようとして
しまいましたごめんなさいちゃんと飲み
ます
ああこの中だとピーチヨーグルトが一番
なんか飲みやすい気がしました美味しいあ
のがね本当にその栄養ガチ勢の味でした
メイバランスバナナヨーグルト味美味しい
のがいい美味しいのがいい美味しいのが
いい
うん
ギリセーフメバランスすごいな結構
ちゃんとえきの食品感がありますねメイ
バランスパン
ヨーグルトやばいもう何がなんだか分から
なくなってきたこれも有名ですね1日分の
ビタミンビタミン13種全部入りいただき
ますうま飲みやすさがい次元ですスーっと
体に入ってきすっとこれでビタミン取れる
んでしょ最高じゃん1日分のビタミン
マスカット味うーん美味しい1日分の
ビタミンピーチ味うん美味しいまるで
スムージー飲むゼリーもスムージーレベル
まで来てるってことか楽しみだないただき
ますうん飲みやすいこれで栄養補給できる
んでしょ大したもんだよ本当に30品目の
野菜と果実大丈夫
かそんなに野菜盛り込むと味がちょっと
心配ですけどもいただき
ます野菜だ野菜だでもカロリー低いから
これ多分すげえヘルシーなんだろうな色が
オレンジ色新色登場だアリナミングレープ
フルーツ味アリナミンも飲みゼリ出てるん
ですねいただきますうん飲みやすい
アリナミングレープ
風味うんさっきの方が好きだったアレナ
アップル
味美味しいさあどんどん混ぜていきますし
あの一口でもねこの量ののり飲むと結構
タプですなんかおいっぱいというよりなん
だろう栄養の取りすぎの感じが来てますね
普通に俺一体どれぐらいローヤルゼリー
入ってんだろう体に取ってはいけない量な
クさんとか多分入ってると思います
どんどん行きましょう朝バナナバナーナ朝
りんごりんご朝マンゴえマンゴーマンゴー
じゃないのリブアップゼリーうん美味しい
リボビダゼリーああみなぎるリボビダン
ゼリースポーツ走りたくなってきたリボン
ゼリーゼロゼサクルミゼリーバナナ&
アサイこのサイクルミーシリーズは7で
売ってるやつなんですよいろんな種類が
あって健康に良さそうなのが多いイメージ
ですいただきますうん飲みやすいサイクル
ミゼリーマスカットのアーモンドミルク
すごい組み合わせだなマスカットと
アーモンドミルク噛み合ってるサイクル
ミゼリーブルーベリー&クランベリー
ベリー
ベリーちょっと待ってね俺
これ一口ずつ飲んでるわけなんですけど
どんだけの栄養素取ってるんだえやばい
多分普通に1か分のマルチビタミン取っ
てる寝れないぞ今日これ多分すごいなんか
みってきてるんです
けどへビタミンレモンゼリーうんレモン
キトレモン算2700ククキューピコは
アルファチゼリー栄養栄養感じますキュー
ピコはチゼリー9ややのみやすいザバスの
リカバリープロティンゼリ筋肉復活
リアップマスカおおうまいうまいごめん
なさいね露骨に分かりやすくて今なところ
なんだけど本当にピンキで栄養に偏りすぎ
て味はどうでもいい言い方がいいのか
わかんないですけど決して美味しくない
ような味のやつもあるしちゃんと美味しい
マスカット風味がなんか美味しいのかな味
に寄ってるのか栄養素に寄ってるのか
みたいな感じがありますそれがガチで
まずいかちょっとわかんないけどもう俺の
主観で言ってるけどこれは美味しかった
です最高ですリバブゼリーマルチビタミン
ゼリー
うんガッツギアスポーツキッズ応援ゼリー
イナズマイレブンのノムゼリーかな
マスカット味うわこれはもうサッカー少年
飲むんでしょうねきっとああやっぱ子供に
飲みやすい味になってる甘くて美味しい白
透明なゼリーの方が珍しいよねガツア
りんご味アポあーこれも透明
だ
やばい
なんか胸が痛くなってきました多分
ローヤルゼリーかアミノさんとクエンさん
の取りすぎですね元気いっぱいなんか飲む
ゼリーってさお菓子のゼリーとは違ってさ
ちゃんと栄養入ってるやつが多いじゃん
全部なんか書いてあるの今のところマルチ
ビタミン入ってますとかタンパ質とか
ローヤルゼリーアミノ酸クエ酸それ全部一
口ずつ飲んでるわけなのでなんか溜まって
きてるんすよね俺多分この世にある
ほとんどの栄養素1週間分ぐらいも
溜め込んでますはいどんどん行きましょう
マルテスムージーバナ&フルーツミックス
アうん本当はスムージーだバームゼリー
98うん本当は9だバームアスリート本当
走りたくなったきバームスマートフィット
ゼリーうんなんかマにフィットしてきた
プラスクイックエとプラスエネルギーうん
本当エネルギー来たクイックエ達ビタミン
滝のなビタミン感じるクイックエドマルチ
ミネラルうんミネラルだこれ味女
ビューティパイナップルスパミジ
ビューティタクロスパミチョビューティ
キャラマチばうやばいめっちゃぱいミチ
ビューティ桃
[音楽]
ば
あ大丈夫です
よ行きましょうリコペンリッチうんトマト
でええ赤いんだろうな絶対赤いんだろうな
ほら赤いアのバトアサク
チャージ
アバ食べた
ヨーグルトタパとマスカット味あベロニカ
和アノベルダイエットエクササイズ
うんあねゼリーでかけた喋りながら飲むの
は良くないですね
クリゼリーまでオーガニックなものがあん
のかサウナポポ
クリポ分にもこちもぜうん甘いこれ
ビタミンが入ってないでしょもう甘すぎて
味で分かるようになってきましたここまで
来ると今まで飲んできた飲むゼリーは
ちゃんとそのなんか栄養とか体にいいもの
入ってるんですけどもこれねコラ揚げが
300mg入ってるだけであとマジでただ
の美味しいゼリーです久々にちゃんと
スイーツきましたシナモロール婚約
ゼリーマジのただのカフェフレだいやいや
茶色くてこの音はそれだな肌の保湿力を
高めるそんなことができんの
ほんまや脂肪を減らすそんなことができん
の
かほんまや稽宝石イスワの時に飲むべきだ
アクアサポートゼリーうん水ポカリ
ちょっと薄い野菜生活すりおろしリゴ結構
リアルだ本物に近いタイプのやつだガシ
ゼリーうまマゼリーあまマゼリマスカット
味おうまい補がれ
たほぼ無アミノバイタルパーフェクト
エネルギーパーフェクトアミノバイタル
ゴールドアミノバイタルスーパースポーツ
スポー飲むぞプレントコンネマスカット
マスカットプレントコグレープ
グレーププルトコオレンジオレンジプルト
コピーチピーチプルトコシでろしもプルト
にミゼロうめプルトに報ゼロうプルトコテ
シインマスカットゼロシャインマスカ
プルトコテミックスフルーツミク飲む酒
ピチたりアンパンマン柔らかにこり
アンパンマン柔らかとりアンパンマン
柔らかみがりくくくくくー鉄分ブド節分
プラピカポケモンゼヨクみポケモンゼブド
みポケモンゼモみポケモンミクスグみ
ポケモンゼイゴフみっぐらしブド
ゼリし
すみっこぐらしりんご
[笑い]
ゼリーすみっこぐらしみか
ゼリもう何も感じませ
ん
全部入れ終わりまし
[音楽]
たやばいなんかただの大食いとは違って
ものすごい量のなんか栄養が体にすごい
天敵めっちゃ打たれたみたいなんよく
わかんないんですけどなんか普通の大食い
とは違うなかやばさを感じましたありえ
ない量の1日のビタミンの摂取量をかなり
大幅にオーバしてる気がしてて逆になんか
ハになってますへはいというわけで日本
国内に売っている飲むゼリー多分全種類
混ぜた状態がこちらになります角度によっ
て全然色が違います
ねはい黄色いのがやっぱり多いかなって
いう気がしてますねあとこの赤いのはブド
とかかなこっちはめちゃくちゃなんか赤い
んですけどこっちはなんか白いのが結構
神伝していたりこっちはなんか美味しそう
な色だねいやそうでもないのなんか離し
てるなここら辺ここも結構分離してますね
上から見るとこんな感じです結構グロい
けどまあまあよく言えばフルーツポンチ
悪く言えばゲロですはいというわけで飲む
ゼリー120種類うごめんなさい
結構ガチで限界です120種類ゼリー全部
飲ませていただいたんですけども特に
美味しかったの2つでしたなんかかけ離れ
ててこの2つがもうトップ2で美味しくて
あとはすいませんあの後半はほぼ記憶と
味覚がなく序盤だったからっていうのも
あるので参考になるか分かりませんが特に
美味しかった2つ紹介したいと思います
なんかそれはそうだっていう結果なんです
けどえこちらの2つ1日分のビタミンと
あのウダイゼリーの普通のやついごめん
なさいやっぱり売れてるものには売れてる
理由がありましたわこの2つがちょっと
ダトで美味しかったです他にも美味しいの
何個があったんですけどもなんかこの栄養
成分とかも考えると美味しいのに栄養も
取れるっていうマジですごい便利だなって
改めて思いましたノムゼリー中にはねあの
本当このこと言いたくないですけども
美味しくなかったやつとかもありましたし
味が結構どぎついのもありましたけどその
分やっぱりしっかり栄養が取れたりとか
絶対体にプラスになるもの入ってるんじゃ
ないかなって思います知らんけどそう信じ
たいですじゃないと嫌ですはいというわけ
で早速これ混ぜて120種類のノムゼリー
をこう混ぜ合わせた結果もうええよやばい
よこれもう万能薬よこれふの山も治ります
120種類のノムゼリーを全て混ぜせてみ
たいと思思います飲むゼリーを研究し開発
している全ての皆様飲むゼリーの全ての
成分味を1つにし史上最強の飲ゼリーを今
作り
ます
[音楽]
やー重い重い
ぞ混ざってるか
な結構混ざってきてる全てのゼリーが
しっかり混ぜるようにしっかり混ぜていき
ます
よしできましたこれが飲むゼリーの集性
サイコバリスティック
ダイナミックトリニティ
ボルケーノオリビオゼリー
[音楽]
ですま色々混ざってますね色の割合として
は黄色が8割赤が1割白が1割で色々
なんか混ざってたりしてオレンジみたいな
部分もあるなっていう印象は受けます匂い
の
方丼物の飯と栄養ドリンクを混ぜた匂い
ですじゃ早速いただきたいと思います
ひすいひすいとしっかり飲みてるよなこれ
ぐらい行っちゃおうかなはいはいはい栄養
満点は間違いないのよもうありとあらゆる
成分含んでますから恐ろしいほどの高能
そしてカツカツの味サ飲みやすい超
スーパー飲むい完成したと思います早速
いただき
[音楽]
ます
あええ割と
いける割といけるぞこれ結構味の薄い
ゼリーも多かったからかななんか飲み
やすいすっきり味になってます
ねうんえちょっと感動なんだけどたまに
まずいたまにまずいけど基本美味しい
ですうんうん
美味しいあのごめんなさいそもそもこれ
飲む前にゼリ飲みすぎてねもう限界みたい
なとこあるんですけどもうお腹いっぱい
あんだけ飲む釣り飲んだ後でもちゃんと
美味しい美味しいというか
まずくはないちゃんと飲めるよっていう味
なのはちょっと感動しましたね何味って
言えばいいんだろうなんかフルーツ感も
そんなないいろんなフルーツ混ざってて
ほのかに香るぐらいのなんかミックス激
ミックスフルーツスポーツドリンクフミ
みたいな感じだと思いますいやこれは大
成功じゃないでしょう
かもう飲めませ
[音楽]
ん
ちょっと今日はもうこれ1人で飲めない
ですあと多分今日じゃなくても1人でこの
ルは飲むことができませんただ必ずや世人
を持って仲間たちと飲みたいと思います
みんな